I think everybody's got something inside
of them that they are probably better at
than most of the other people in the
world we're wired to pick up safety and
security concerns above everything else
first lessons top performers in any
industry sort of discover is that if you
go right at the thing you're most afraid
of that's where all your super power is
like you just have to learn to take rest
over and over and over again so ladies
and gentlemen I have a special guest
with me today I'm super excited got a
new book called the future is faster
than you think Steven Kotler in the
house
this book is wild it talks about the
future of pretty much every single
industry health government business
finance all of it I'm here to pick his
big brain and see what we can learn
Steven welcome aboard man thanks for
having me Evan so my audience is mostly
entrepreneurs either people are in
business or want to be entrepreneurs
what what do you hope people take from
this book because there's so many
different paths you can go down and so
many macro trends you're talking about
what's the big takeaway you'd think for
entrepreneurs you know it's it's funny I
think if you ask me if you ask my
co-writer Peter Diamandis
you know who we really wrote this book
for I think entrepreneurs they always
top our lists and the reason is as you
pointed out the book maps out the change
we're gonna see over the next 10 years
in every industry and it's massive right
though the overwhelming impact of the
book on most people is holy crap I can't
believe how much change is coming right
and if you sort of work the numbers it's
roughly a hundred years where the
technological change shrunk into ten
years the upside of that for our
different errors is we believe more
wealth it's going to be creative over
the next 10 years and we've seen over
the past hundred there's massive massive
amounts of opportunity and the reason is
the book really tracks a bunch of
different exponentially accelerating
technologies rights of technologies that
are doubling in power on a regular basis
Moore's Law being the classic examples
that says our transistors get twice as
fast right every 18 months or so the
cost stays the same so this same force
is showing up in 10 or 11 different
exponential technologies what we know
for starters is whenever technology goes
at
potential we basically find an internet
sized opportunity inside right and while
the internet took a bunch of jobs
it created 2.6 jobs for everyone it took
right so there was a lot of an airship
built on top of that the same thing is
happening with all these Exponential's
but right now over the next 10 years so
they're just individually lines of
accelerated Exponential's they're
starting to converge right AI very
powerful technology robotics very
powerful technology you put them
together and suddenly tens of millions
of US jobs are threatened
alright so when you get converging
Exponential's the size of the disruption
increases is this good news for
traditional companies no traditional
companies are gonna have to adapt to a
rate of change speed to change the level
of change like they've never seen before
and they're not really built for that
but entrepreneurs are exactly built for
that so I think for entrepreneurs it's
an incredibly exciting time that we're
going into you have these seven forces
that you talk about in the book and and
one of my favorites was around genius
and if I can read a line you said until
recently most genius was squandered even
if you were born with incredible talents
the chances of you being able to use
those abilities was limited at best one
of the things I talk to a lot of people
in my channel about it it's in almost
every video is I tell people that
they're a genius that you have Michael
Jordan level talent at something you got
to find it and then use it to go make an
impact on the world I kind of wish that
was your whole book I love that that
little section you have on there could
you could you expand more on what you
think about people's genius be able to
find it and why now is a great time to
be with leverage it there sure and
there's the argument we're making is
threefold one is discovery right well
opportunity and discovery until very
recently if you weren't white and male
and wealthy your chances of getting
beyond a second grade education were
extremely limited that is no longer the
case anybody with access to the Internet
right which is more and more most of us
over 4 billion of us at this point
have all the information all the
education we could possibly desire free
of charge so that's starting to change
and as a result more people are getting
educated for sure
more people who have genius within them
are being able to tap into it but even
if you just kind of look at the standard
you know number of geniuses that show up
in any population until recently we
couldn't find them right if you were
born genius in the wrong location in the
LOC wrong village couldn't get access to
the learning materials couldn't blossom
and we couldn't find you anyhow right so
giant networks means we can on earth
genius way more often and that's just I
think part a I think part B and C is
most of the work well the other half of
the work I do besides working on
disruptive technologies I work on peak
human performance I study kind of the
neurobiology of flow which is an optimal
state of consciousness where we feel our
best and we perform our best and all the
like I don't know how we're gonna define
genius but we see massive amplification
and cognitive skills when we move into
flow motivation learning creativity
innovation cooperation collaboratory
things go through the roof in flow and
what's really interesting is because
biotechnology is moving so quickly
sensors are moving so quickly ai is
moving so quickly this convergence we
are being able to kind of peel back the
hood on flow see where it's coming from
why it's coming how do we get more of it
this is amazing for ability to keep pace
in an accelerated world flow appears to
be out the only time that the brain kind
of thinks its scale can perform at speed
so it allows us to keep up we get more
genius as a result and finally brain
computer interfaces right are advancing
at exponential speeds and you know
already we've got quadriplegics moving
cursors with their mind inside of
computers they stated experiment
essentially in telepathy where they sent
signals from a research lab in France to
the brain of somebody in India and back
and forth they played a video game where
computers we've now have movies that
change depending on our brain waves this
is stuff is getting more and more invest
we're nowhere near primetime we're not
we're not we don't have AI in our brains
anytime soon but it's coming a lot
faster than most people assume so I
think a our ability to find more genius
in the world train that genius up going
way up
we're gigging under the hood of what do
we mean by genius we're getting at the
neuro by
we're getting fantastic at training that
up and that short-term long-term brain
computer interfaces artificial
intelligence all these things can be
tools that will unlock much more genius
in us so I think it's a triple answer
but I think it's cool yeah if we expand
the definition of genius beyond just
high IQ and maybe say everybody or at
least being able to be the best in the
world that's something do you think
that's successful that everybody is at a
certain percentage like that people
could be the best in the world that's
something to just don't know what it is
so I haven't you know I'm a
science-based guy I haven't seen a ton
of data on what you're saying that said
personal opinion my experience in the
real world and certainly my experience I
spent the first 25 years of my career as
a journalist right and going out into
the world and I specialized in those
moments in time when the impossible
became possible so whether is in
business for technology or science or
athletics whenever we saw somebody do
something that nobody thought was gonna
be done right I was often there trying
to figure out why it was done what the
hell happened and certainly all these
people had something inside of
themselves that nobody else had and they
had taken it much farther and it one of
its everything was very individual right
like what the the impossible person
chose it sort of always matched who they
were when you saw up close sort of made
sense in that way and I tend to in a
folk psychology kind of way I agree with
you I think everybody's got something
inside of them that they are probably
better at than most of the other people
in the world are the best top 5%
probably or the top 1% doubtful because
there's probably a bunch of genetic
stuff nature-nurture stuff that weaves
into it but top 5% yeah I would start to
believe that under the right conditions
so why are people settling for a job at
some company they hate instead of about
you chasing down what their top 5% is I
can't give you an easy answer and I you
know and I'm sure you've asked this
question to a lot of people I've gotten
a lot of really smart answers and I'm
and I hope I'm not repeating too many of
them but
think it's first of all um we have hard
wiring problems first and foremost on
the brain takes in a ton information
every second but the first stop most of
that information makes is our danger
detector right we're wired to pick up
safety and security concerns above
everything else money is this
fundamental safety and security concern
and it eats at people so people and and
by the way we process sort of physical
danger in the same parts of the brain
that we process financial danger right
it's the same sort of things we can't
really tell the difference
money fear is a primal safety and
security concern so one part of your
answer is we get scared and write every
every single person I know um when I was
coming up as a writer who was also
chasing a creative dream every person
got derailed this way right they were
chasing their dream tracing the dream it
was hard it was hard it was hard and
somebody offered them a job felt like
like have an editor do you're a writer
he or have an editor job you're really
really talented you can write on the
side but you can't something you're an
editor you're not a writer that's a real
job with a full plate of
responsibilities but it does come with a
paycheck so you're safer you're more
secure and I think that some version of
that psychology is everywhere right
interestingly my friend Philip Rosedale
who created Second Life that virtual
world did a really interesting study of
entrepreneurship and cities that foster
entrepreneurship and he was looking at
conditions that led to it in San
Francisco was really at the top of the
list but not for the reasons that you
would think you ended up at the top of
the list because if you weren't
entrepreneur and your company went out
of business
you had the biggest most robust network
and the fastest way to get another job
in San Francisco so it was really safety
and secured the city because there was
so much entrepreneurship there's so many
jobs go to floating around was providing
a safety net that auditors didn't have
elsewhere so I think III you know fear
is the FIR is my first answer there's a
lot there's a lot of long answers behind
that but you have to you have to figure
out how to negotiate that gone
what so diving into fear I'm curious
about your perspective on this hack when
speaking on stage does that there's a
number of successful speakers who say
don't say you're nervous say you're
excited because it's the same feeling
yeah it's the same neuro chemistry so
it's not entirely true but
neurobiologically fear and anxiety and
excitement are both norepinephrine so
there's a really funny study they did at
Harvard where they look at you might
have heard this they looked at can you
use breathing to down regulate the
nervous system to calm down versus
reframing and you're talking about
reframing right so they had them say
hold that feeling of that fear their
anxiety in their body and say I am
excited three times out loud and that
output massively outperform trying to
breathe your way into calm and it's
because the signals are the same and
reframing is a really powerful tool so I
have a different kind of reframe and
maybe I'm just saying we were duck and
I'm really curious about your
perspective so so the reframe is
typically you're nervous no you're not
nervous you're excited for me it's like
no I'm nervous and I do nervous things
like I do the things that make me
nervous and that's where my self
confidence comes from hey I think that's
true and everyone and I think I think
one of the first lessons top performers
in any industry sort of discover is that
if you go right at the thing you're most
afraid of that's where all your
superpowers lie right every one of your
kryptonite's becomes your superpowers
and it seems like we're sort of
hardwired can make that transition it's
almost how we learn so if you can't get
comfortable being uncomfortable there's
absolutely nothing you can do in kind of
peak human performance that's the fact
sort of the foundational rule so what I
hear don't tell yourself you're nervous
you're excited it feels like at least
for me you're telling yourself that
you're weak because you need this hack
so it's an you've come up against one of
those really interesting paradoxes in
peak performance in human performance
and it's um so let me back into it a
different way but in in in in positive
psychology we know one of the best
ways to sort of take in more positive
information instead of negative
informations and is and sort of one of
the best ways to impact happiness is a
gratitude practice right because it
trains the brain to focus on the
positive instead of the negative but it
doesn't focus on the imaginary positive
and that's that's why affirmations the
secret don't don't work it's because
you've got a great internal [ __ ]
detector and if you're working at
Walmart you can't look in the mirror and
say I'm a millionaire I'm a millionaire
I'm a millionaire because your brain is
going no you're not
clearly you're not it's like all
evidence to the contrary
really so reframing is a psychological
trick the truth of the matter is anxiety
excitement are the exact same singles
right for you though it's a sign of
weakness either way and you've got an
entirely different psychological
construct around it and this like you've
built a bigger frame than the actual
biology that's how it works right so
you've sort of changed the rules on
yourself so you isn't that particularly
system won't work for you I tend to UM
agree with you and I tend to think there
are a lot of different ways sort of to
do that I tend to think I want to
reframe and if that doesn't work right
if I'm still nervous one of the next
things I do is I ask myself well do I
have enough information to be nervous
right am i nervous about a test I'm
gonna take two weeks from now
I haven't take the take of the test yet
so this is a false signal it's letting
me know I need to prepare that's the
information nothing right so you can
there are more steps that I will add in
to reframe and underneath it and I think
sort of starts to solve your problem but
yeah it's a paradox even performance I
love it I mean before going live we're
talking about the Doritos and you asked
me if three-toes sponsored this show or
not and explained no I have a de Madrid
Oh strategy the fact that if I want to
eat healthy and I want to eat Doritos
the answer is not get rid of them from
my house but how them right in front of
me all day long because this makes me
stronger because comes from doing
typical things I always couch it in like
I'm weird I'm a weird duck it may not
work for you but I'm curious about your
you know your you're the expert on peak
performance what do you think I uh I
think you just said something really
really wise so the way I always explain
it to people is that
as a general rule will work for me isn't
gonna work for you and the reason is
that personality built on nature and
nurture doesn't tend to scale biology
scales so evolution designed us to
perform at our best in a kind of a
specific way so thinkers going all the
way back to William James Wright first
psychology American psychologist wrote
the first psychological textbook he
pointed out that the great thing and
every education is to make your nervous
system your ally rather than your enemy
and what he really means is a lot of
what we mean by peak performance is
getting your biology to work for you
rather than against you so if you can
kind of work this stuff backwards to
neurobiology to mechanism right basic
mechanism that does sort of work for
everybody right but the minute you start
let me tell you how to live your life
and I'll give you like true story
personal story I learned this sifts the
hard way everybody who knows anything
about Putin learns anything about peak
performance makes the same mistake you
get a little wise and then you start
telling people usually the people you
love the most how to live their lives
right you just do it it just happens
learning comes with ego inflation you're
like oh I figured now let me tell you
how to live your life in my case when I
like I had a couple years of kind of
flow science under my belt and you know
I nearly caused a divorce I put two
different people in the hospital like I
was the biggest disaster known to man
know right and I finally realized I was
like whoa you know I've got crazy like
psycho work ethic I've also got psycho
Jewish neuroticism a relentlessly Jewish
much like like my balance is very
peculiar and I'm really risk friendly I
like big risk so that combination all my
was working for me was killing other
people and I that was so I learned that
lesson that personality doesn't scale
biology scales really early in my career
thank God but I think and I think it's
one of the things that's wrong in a lot
of the kind of the peak performance
world right now is people have magically
figured out works for them great that's
fantastic that's part of the game but
just because it worked in you it doesn't
work for other people so the idea of
saying no I'm nervous I'm not excited or
danda Doritos is really different ways
of saying I like doing difficult things
like it's difficult I wanted
up into it so just personality or is
that biology so okay so now it gets a
little more complicated but um flow is a
state of optimal performance right it is
how evolution shaped us to perform at
our best right and when we say flow just
for you know broader perspective I'm
talking about those moments of rapt
attention and total absorption you get
so focused on the task at hand that
everything else just seems to disappear
time passes strangely it speeds up five
hours go by in like five minutes right
sometimes it slows down self disappears
self-criticism that inner critic goes
really quiet and all aspects of
performance both mental and physical go
through the roof and flow states
turns out have triggers preconditions
that lead to more flow first is really
odd the idea here is really simple that
flow follows focus it can only show up
when all of our attention is focused on
right here right now so what all these
triggers do they drive attention in the
present moment so the golden rule of
flow the most important of all the
triggers discovered by me hi chick
Sunday hi back in the 70s extremely well
validated is what's known as the
challenge skills balance we pay the most
attention to the task at hand when the
challenge of the task slightly exceeds
our skill set you want to stretch but
not snap right and there's a sweet spot
so the answer your question is more
complicated because yes you want to be
facing your fears but you want to be
doing it inside that stretch but note
step bandwidth right and we talked about
this emotionally we said that midpoint
is not on but very near the midpoint
between boredom and anxiety boredom is
there's not enough stimulation here I'm
not paying any attention anxiety well
way too much right I'm paying too much
attention in between is what researchers
call the flow Channel right physiologist
called the herb stops and curb and you
know there's a bunch of different names
for it but it's the Golden Rule for flow
and so if you can stay in this channel I
am constantly challenging myself and
outside my comfort zone as you're
talking about but you're not too far
outside your comfort zone and this by
the way is another thing that's tricky
you want to set really high our goals
big huge adacia skulls right um also
important for entrepreneurs but you need
to chunk them down so what you're doing
today
it's just a little bit outside your
sweet spot setting a Paillard goal
standard motivation theory tells you
gives you a 10 to 25 percent boost in
motivation that's kind of huge right at
the upper end of that that's like giving
two hours of free work a day if you work
an eight-hour day simply for having like
the right goal around like the problem
you're trying to solve that's a big
thing but if that is a huge goal right I
want to write the Great American Novel
well you can't do that today today you
can write 750 good words that Great
American Novel that right that's a much
more chunk down manageable goal that
keeps you inside that challenge skills
sweet spot so the answer is yes right
like your Doritos are keeping you inside
that challenge skills sweet spot right
it's right there
uncomfortable right but you can do it so
it's leading to sort of traumatic growth
in a sense right that's where that's
where taking you and there's a whole
literature on this right on traumatic
growth and these ideas if you were to I
don't know what your super weaknesses
are maybe it's Doritos but maybe if I
put a full buffet of chocolate eclairs
and doughnuts and everything else in
front of you everyday might that might
tip you out right like you might be like
okay no this is overwhelmed Bella be
anxious around this is no longer working
but the bag of Doritos right and
probably the bag of the Doritos is in
fact that like you've got a million
people turning in all the time to notice
in the bag has it moved it has a bit
opened it you haven't cheated right that
keeps you right there in that sweet spot
but it would be you know my loose
diagnostic as you were talking about all
those sweets my mouth is watering so
much I might say sorry that nobody hears
what I do this is great like I'd switch
it to say it's the best like if that was
right in front of me here's what I would
do I would pick it up just smell in all
of the goodness and then put it down and
walk away
and then like Pat myself on the back to
say I'm amazing for doing that so I mean
like I love you know that's how you do
it I don't I don't have that kind of
relationship with ten temptation I
needed a little farther away from me
actually I don't think I but I will tell
you you know both as a writer ad as an
athlete
I ski a lot and I absolutely hate the
time that I hate being afraid to do
something I cannot live with the feeling
of being afraid most of the time I have
to I have to go right at it and going
right at that fear over and over and
over again as both how I progressed as a
writer and as an athlete right over my
old career and it's how everybody does
see that like I don't think we get
better any other way right you've chosen
to wrestle this particular demon in
terms of food right I wrestle at
different ways but I think everybody has
different demons is my point here well
what are you saying we have to do it
like attacking fear is biological it's
inside everybody I think so first of all
and this is not my work this is uh my
friend Andrew humans work at Stanford as
a neuroscientist at Stanford so Andrew
discovered that the fight-or-flight
response in the brain is actually sort
of split and we have a fight response
then we have a freeze and flee response
and they're sort of separate pathways we
love activating the fight response it
produces a tremendous amount of pleasure
we like that experience of fighting back
up standing up to a challenge so that
there is some biology there for sure I
just believe and I think you do too that
not like you know I've risk-taking is
fundamental to doing amazing things in
this world it just is right and going at
your fear is foundational that you know
you're not you were talking earlier
about creative genius you know one of
the things that we know if you just go
to the simplest psychological definition
of creativity which is the creative the
creation of ideas that are novel and
useful the useful part means you got to
introduce you to the world you got to
say hey world here's what I came up with
what do you think is it useful that is
always going to be scary no matter what
oh so you risk-taking is sort of built
into init innovation and I think
innovation is built into survival so on
those levels yeah absolutely I'm saying
this is biological I also think a repeat
performance perspective if you can't you
just have to learn to take risks over
and over and over again in fact one of
the things we know about one of
downsides of flow they say is that this
was work done in Germany the more more
access to flow you get one of the things
because this challenge skills balance we
know over time you will keep taking
bigger and bigger risks
so if flow is the state of optimal
performance right and you want to keep
getting into flow you have to sort of
keep taking bigger and bigger and bigger
risks as you go along and that's just
that's just part of it I think I think
it sort of comes with it because your
comfort zone is expanding because your
comfort zone is expanding and I also
think and I think you might agree with
me I the thing that I'm really
interested in these days a lot and you
can see it on a lot of the people you
talk to what it wonders are sort of all
over the place especially with the
internet now right but like a long
sustained creative career which isn't
about a first act or a second act it's a
third act for them if that sticks that
kind to constant self reinvention right
that comes with constantly finding new
challenges and that kind I also think
anybody I've ever met who has actually
accomplished the impossible right done
what we've never done before has gone
through that gauntlet as well every
Beatles album was different they really
had to reinvent themselves
well like greatest or one of the
greatest of all time flow so this was
easy for me because as in all my
research on you it's it's talking about
flow State and the books and the videos
in the talks how do you balance flow
which is very in the present in the
moment losing hours and in your book
which is talking about the future that's
coming I always so let me let me be
really clear on tubes to wait to
big-picture ways one is I always say
whenever you see the impossible become
possible you see two things right you
see people learning to harness
disruptive accelerating technology and
you see people finding ways to expand
human capability those two things come
together that's how you get the
impossible I also think so the futures
faster than you think is a book about
massive acceleration and Technology
massive acceleration in society the ream
taking of pretty much every industry
over the next 10 years it's about
exponential growth problem we have
linear brains literally we our brains
evolve in an area that was local and
linear right local meaning everything we
dealt with one day's walk away linear
rate of change was really slow its
global and exponential today and the
brain literally cannot keep up we have
what's known as a linear bias it's a
cognitive bias that doesn't allow us to
see exponential growth on and on and on
in fact here's a funny thing so if I say
Evan imagine just close your eyes for
half a second and imagine yourself ten
years from now just see what you're
wearing see what you're doing okay open
your eyes now so when you think about
yourself right if I say Evan think about
yourself right now your medial
prefrontal cortex right here is gonna
get active this is sort of creative
self-expression it gets really active
when we think about ourselves when we
think about other people it tends to
shut off and like you think about loved
ones it deactivates a little bit more
and then associates a little bit further
distant strangers it's totally shut down
when you think about that you that
you're gonna become in ten years that
portion of the brain shuts down
in other words future you is not you
know psychologically this is why we have
hard time staying on diets or getting
prostate exams or saving room for
retirement because you who's gonna
benefit most from that stuff is
literally not you from a neurobiological
perspective um and most of us have
roughly sixty six month time horizons
we're sort of good at stretching it out
a little bit farther we can do it but at
ten years we're almost all gone we just
can't see farther into the future so
we've got local and linear brains we
don't project well into the future in
fact when we start trying to think about
the future we turn off this is really
really problematic the only time that's
not true
appears to be inflow inflow this the
neural chemicals that produce the state
surround the brains information
processing machine euros we take in more
data per second data acquisition
information acquisition goes up we pay
more attention to that data so salience
increases we find faster connections
between the incoming information or
older ideas so we'll pattern recognition
and lateral thinking that outside the
box that can goes way up this is why
creativity goes up and flow but what it
means is that
when we're in flow it's sort of the only
time the brain can think at speed and
it's scale in fact interestingly because
our sense of self and self consciousness
disappears in flow we can actually see
farther into the future and keep the
medial prefrontal cortex active so it
appears to be the way we get around this
which is not surprising because it
appears that flow is how evolution
shaped the brain to innovate but it's
massively amplified learning creativity
motivation it's a innovators dream
collaboration cooperation all that stuff
is really amped up we do our best
innovating and flow and this is what the
data shows right anytime you see a
paradigm shifting breakthrough you're
seeing a flow state so I don't know if
that totally answers your question but I
hope I got close I know I like it I like
the extra context I guess for people
listening and they're trying to make
this practical this is where the future
is going what do I do right now because
you cover pretty much war industry and
all every trend that's happening that's
coming up great I'm an entrepreneur what
am I gonna do right now so I'm not just
distracted by yes we're all gonna you
know upload our consciousness and say oh
yeah of course know what I mean you know
what you want to know and this is the
cool thing about exponential growth is
it's it follows a linear a predictable
pattern like we know where it's gonna go
we have you know full maps on it and you
know I mean that the fast answer is you
got I mean the self-serving answers read
the book because you absolutely have to
understand what's coming there's no way
right this book was written especially
for entrepreneurs to prepare them for
the future here's the future these are
all the opportunities and they're like
you know my favorite example in the book
um is some of the opportunities for
entrepreneurs one of the reasons it's so
important to kind of get where the
technology is going and by the way get
back to figure out how to get him to
flow so we can utilize all this stuff
but where the a lot of the opportunity
is in these weird mashup markets that's
what we're seeing so a bunch of years
ago I was giving a speech at NBC and I
was talking to them about where their
business was going and so at the flow
Research collective we have a bunch of
neuroscientists on our board and we work
with and one of them is out of Ghazali Z
you know
of San Francisco University of
California San Francisco and this year
2020 next year 2020 Adam has a video
game coming out that literally treats
cognitive decline in adults so in older
adults
it can take 60 year-old brains and sort
of reset small parts of them to the
brains of a 20 year old and what its
gonna be FDA it's already FDA approved
so it means you're gonna go to the
doctor you've got aging right signs of
aging the doctor is gonna say okay go
home and play this video game an hour a
day for the next three weeks right and
that's how we're gonna treat it's not a
pill it's a video game
so what I told the NBC I was like this
is where we are right now today right
2030 let me ask you a question are you
gonna go to the movies you're gonna go
to the movie that makes you smarter are
you gonna play a video game you're gonna
play a video game that treats something
healthcare and entertainment are coming
together in a way that nobody great
nobody really saw coming
but it's happening we're getting mash up
market sitting between right so 10 years
from now an entertainment company in a
neuroscience company sort of the same
thing all right so you have to we have
to know where the future where these
things are going just so you can
understand oh my god
these are the crazy opportunities right
like so you need that and then I think
you need to know how to get into flow
which is entirely trainable that's one
of the things that we've discovered um
to really maximize these things I've to
me it's a two-step formula and I don't
think Peter Diamandis my co-author we
disagree at all like self education and
training seems to be the only way you
can get in front of this stuff it's
amazing it's crazy how time flies when
you're having fun I didn't know quite
where the interview would go but I was
strapped in for a wild ride and you
definitely delivered the book is called
the future is faster than you think
we're gonna link it up in the
description below go check it out
Stephen really appreciate your insights
and thank you for making this book -
thank you having fun to be with you take
care if you want to see the one on one I
did with sadguru check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there nobody can cause mental
pain to you
it is you
in the reaction to something that
happens around you